it's poverty the new minimalism now
there's something when I hear this a
question like this it's it's it comes
across to me as accusatory and that says
something about me mm-hm and what's
going on inside of me yeah I don't know
help me work through that real quick
like is this first off is this someone
on patreon no this is from Twitter I
just sent out its again okay for my
personal so yeah so yeah it's so that's
makes sense that it's not from someone
on patreon that someone someone from
Twitter would this that makes a lot of
sense to me okay so my suspicion is true
no no it's it's not all bad it's just a
matter of someone who's paying to hear
this right now uh-huh don't they don't
seem like they would ask a question like
that because they understand they
already know the answer to that question
right this is again it to me it comes
across as an accusatory question well
let's talk about it so so someone's
asking this question because they're
confused and so here's the biggest thing
I've learned from TK when he's on our
podcast I think he's been on our podcast
six times now and and we've been friends
he and I have long conversations outside
of the podcast as well and the thing
that I learned most from him is giving a
charitable view even to someone who like
like with David literally lashing out of
me and you know saying some pretty
insulting things I figure out what
question it was that you took that
you're like TK help me have a charitable
view like that would I loved how you
approach that man it made it inspired me
to like sort of pro Qing things like
that more but I see him do that every
day and it just is every day we have a
conversation he will try to take the
other side just to steal man his own
argument the opposite of a straw man
argument it's a steal man argument bill
is your own up by looking at the the
best possible argument against your side
and so so if I'm if I'm going to steal
man my own argument let me let me talk
about poverty here this person is
confused they are conflating a few
things here they're conflating
having nothing or next to nothing or
deprivation with minimalism that's easy
to do and let me explain why it's easy
to do often minimalism was propagated in
especially in the media as owning
nothing right you look at someone like
Marie Kondo is I sent you a funny meme
recently she's like holding a gun and
says you know our spark joy goodbye did
she ever even use the word minimalism I
don't think she does I don't but it's
it's I don't know well she is also
translation errors right Khushi so she
doesn't speak English
yeah let me I'm sure she speaks more
English words than I speak Japanese
words but she's not fluent in English
and so we have these translation errors
as well when when she talks about
sparking joy whoever translated that
really meant sparking happiness right
right
joy comes only from our interaction with
others and I have this my favorite part
in the new book is where I really go
through and and dissect the well-being
continuum yeah and we talked about
tranquility and equanimity and we talked
about pleasure and happiness and
contentment enjoy the difference between
those things and and I think that when
when we're talking of minimalism at its
extreme it appears that it's owning
nothing
and so you it's easy to confuse well a
few oh nothing then that's the same
thing as a poor person right it's
absolutely wrong by the way you and I
grew up really poor
we owned way more stuff when we were
really poor than when we did now oh yeah
because we weren't intentional right now
we were really really poor I mean about
as poor as you can get in America we
were and the thing about being poor too
is when something is offered for free
you take it because I have to but you
often do yes because it's it's like oh
well I don't have the money to buy that
certain thing and I mean I need that
thing right but I might need it in the
future so there's this sense of scarcity
and if something is offered to you for
free like we would jump on I mean dude
every single
piece of furniture that my mother had
growing up it was out of the trash every
single piece yeah someone puts it on the
curb and you go yeah yeah exactly yeah
we did very similar things or goodwill
at best or thrift shop whatever and and
so I could see why you would conflate
that and and I'm sorry that you conflate
conflated it that way and so let me do a
good better job of explaining that
minimalism is about the intentional use
of our resources it starts with the
stuff but then it goes so far beyond the
stuff it's about being intentional with
the people we bring into our lives and
the people we keep in our life and we'll
dive more into that in a moment
it's about being intentional with our
creativity and how we spend our time we
spend our time it's it's so funny Ryan
if we were to we we often will get very
concerned about I couldn't possibly
the patrons know how much their time is
worth yeah because they're you're
spending $2 on this conversation or five
dollars if you're one of the true fans
right or eight dollars if you're one of
the VIPs and thank you no matter what
level you're at there amen but the thing
that you understand is that your time is
worth it we don't fill our podcast with
ads and you're buying a ad-free version
of the podcast and not only are you
doing that you're supplying the people
who can't afford the two dollars and add
free version as well yeah so you're
going you're you're actually providing a
community service to the hundreds of
thousands of people who listen to our
podcast one the three million downloads
a month your your so you're supplying
you know your the 1% of people who were
supplying a community service to the
other 99% and you're actually giving
them some of their time back yeah you're
being ultra considerate and isn't that
what we're talking about minute
minimalism being considerate with the
resources you have including your time
your money your community and if you're
being intentional it doesn't mean by the
way you don't have to have a certain
amount of money to be intentional with
all of your resources money is one
resource by the way wouldn't it
make more sense if you have very little
money I left the corporate world Ryan
2011 you know I made $23,000 that year
the year before that I made about just
almost $200,000 right I was still broke
I spent more than two hundred thousand
oh yeah you didn't it sound like you
walked away and had $100,000 sitting you
had sixteen thousand dollars when I
walked away yeah yeah yeah I got a
severance back right yeah I negotiated a
severance pay no no by the way you had a
huge unexpected tax bill you had to pay
that's absolutely true yeah yes and and
so I had enough money for about one was
all said and done about four months of
paying rent in my bills and so I I had
some time to figure it all out right and
and that was that was great but it
wasn't nearly right if I would have been
responsible with those resources those
like that but that decade I would had
years worth of a yeah I would had years
worth of a safety net and by the way if
the first 20 years of my life when I was
also broke wouldn't I have benefited
when am i mom benefited or family
benefited from being more intentional
with the few with a little bit of money
that we had wouldn't we have benefited
from being more intentional with using
our time mm-hmm using our time
deliberately wouldn't we have benefited
from being more creative and in using
our time to create rather than consume
we wouldn't we have benefited from
surrounding ourselves with people who
shared our values not just our proximity
you know if we were more intentional
with the people in our life wouldn't we
have benefited from that there was one
area my mom was very intentional in her
life with and it was with community she
did a phenomenal job and I write about
this and love people use things she
every year this is just one example but
she would she would organize this annual
Thanksgiving dinner and sometimes she
would feed people who weren't even as
poor as us but in the way she organized
she got grocery stores to donate turkeys
and this
grocery store to donate potato salad and
this seamstress to donate napkins and
and and you know cutlery or whatever and
like the whole community would come
together we had it in the basement of
this church on Warren Street and it
every year if we we would have this
200-300 people show up to this thing
some people have more money than us some
people were homeless or near homeless
and she would feed people for
Thanksgiving and she did that all the
time with these community things and so
people knew her in the community even
though we didn't have any money she was
very intentional with that resource